[Music]
all hail queen bee I sneezed on the beat
and the beat the singer brought down the
house at Coachella for the second
weekend in a row
Beyonce mostly kept the same setlist as
weekend one performing with her hubby
jay-z and reuniting with her Destiny's
Child bandmates Kelly Rowland and
Michelle Williams but she did shake
things up with a new surprise guest
Latin singer J Balvin he also swapped
out her costumes debuting a series of
sparkly new wardrobe changes custom-made
by Beaumont and looked flawless in this
cape and Crown the 36 year old was
joined again on stage by her sister
Solange Knowles but hit the floor when
she tried to pick up her baby sis among
those in the crowd for beefs performance
Jessica Alba and Katie Holmes who posed
it up with the singer and her mom Tina
Knowles after the show
Caty famously fangirled over Beyonce's
Super Bowl performance during a stop by
the Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon
in 2016
oh my god she did not oh my god oh my
god and then it was like queen bee you
know trying to do that now
[Music]